Uh,
unfortunately,
uh,
I was,
I was reading that and then I got on a flight and I just wanted to zone out and
said,
listen to this one on tape.
Okay.
All right,
well I'll tell you all about it.
Um,
but the key thing is that that book,
the calling the American mind was something that we wrote because Greg began
observing this weird stuff happening in universities in 2014.
It all starts in 2014.
Um,
most of your listeners have heard about safe spaces,
microaggressions,
bias,
response teams,
trigger warnings,
all that stuff.
That stuff didn't exist before 2014.
It just begins creeping in then.
And then it kind of blows up in 2015 and so her whole book is an explanation of
why,
why did this happen?
And so to your question about,
was there an event I or answer is there are six different causal threads.
There's like all these social trends,
some going back to the eighties and nineties that came together around 2014 so
that students are a little different.
And then there are certain forces acting on them that are different.
And so you get this weird new game,
you get this explosive mix,
you get some students who are actually very drawn to grievance studies.
Uh,
and so,
um,
very briefly like the,
it's things like,
um,
rising political polarization.
So left and right.
Never particularly liked each other.
But in the seventies and eighties,
if you look at surveys done of how much you hate people in the other side,
it's not that intense.
It begins going up in the,
in the 80s,
and then especially after 2000,
it's going up very steeply.
Uh,
at the same time,
university faculty who've always leaned left throughout the 20th century,
uh,
but it was only a lien and in the 90s,
it begins shifting much further left so that now faculties,
especially in the social sciences and humanities are pretty purified.
They're overwhelmingly on the left.
So you have a more left leaning university at a time when left.
Right.
Hostility is getting more and more intense.
And so any question that has a political valence,
now there's a lot more people that want to do the football game,
not the truth seeking,
but then we got to defeat the other side.
Don't give me nuance,
don't give me data.
We know what we believe and dammit we're going to,
you know,
so he got this changing political situation and then you've got a couple of
threads about what we've done to kids.
So,
um,
uh,
and to have,
God,
this is a whole nother area conversation for us,
but we basically took away free play and gave them social media the same
basically kids who were born in 1995 and after Gen z they had really different
childhoods and they're not as prepared for conflict and,
and college.
And we'll get into that later.
But you put all these things together,
you get kids who are much more anxious and fragile,
much more depressed,
um,
coming onto campus at a time of much greater political activism.
And now these grievance studies ideas about America's a matrix of oppression and
look at the world in terms of good versus evil.
It's more appealing to them.
And it's that minority of students.
They're the ones who are initiating a lot of the movements.
Such a strange time to be on the,
and watch
this because a person like myself is always counted on intellectuals and
professors and people like yourself to sort of make sense of things and to
reinforce the idea that freedom of speech and free debate are critical aspects
to knowledge.
And one of the things that's most disturbing you see in schools is people that
are even marginally right leaning or centrist being called Nazis and being
silenced,
and they're pulling fire alarms when they're speaking.
And even people like Christina Hoff summers who's a feminist gets shouted down
and,
and people yelling at her and calling her a fascist.
It's just very strange.
It's very strange to watch from the outside.
And it's also very strange to not see any pushback by the professors.
So sitting here and seeing this happen and thinking,
well,
these poor kids,
they're,
they're going to have to go into the workplace.
They're going to have to,
they're there right now during this very insulated environment.
They're going to escape that environment when they graduate.
And then they're either going to push this ideology,
uh,
into the workforce,
which you do see now that's a,
especially with 10 classmates.
Yeah,
that's right.
Now.
That's right.
I know it's strange to look at it from the outside and believe me,
it's stranger from the inside.
But one thing I can say that,
um,
that might be helpful here is that from the outside,
what you see is the news reports and the news reports are going to be very
selective.
And so especially what happens is because,
you know,
universities have always leaned left and so the right leaning media have always
been suspicious.
So the right leaning media has huge coverage of every little thing.
And sometimes it's,
it's exaggerated.
Sometimes it's misinterpreted.
Um,
the most time there was something there,
left leaning media tends to ignore it.
And so I go around the country and you know,
people in the right expect that,
oh my God,
it's chaos and mob violence on campus,
which isn't true.
That's an exaggeration.
And the left is like,
problem,
what problem?
There's nothing changing.
Um,
and so I think the key thing to keep in mind here is that there's about 4,500
institutions of higher education in this country.
Most of them are not selective schools.
They'll take anyone who comes,
um,
and in those schools,
not much is happening.
But if you go to the elite liberal arts colleges in the northeast and the west
coast,
then usually something is happening.
And so,
uh,
at Heterodox Academy,
it's a group that I cofounded a professors that are pushing back.
It's bipartisan.
We have as many people on the,
on the left is on the right.
Um,
we created a map of where all the shout tons have taken place and they're all
right in the northeast or along the Pacific coast,
like from,
you know,
evergreen,
down to Berkeley and all that.
Uh,
and then a couple in Chicago.
So from,
in most of the country this stuff is not happening.
Most schools,
the culture hasn't really changed much,
but at the top schools in general,
it has.
Um,
so that's one thing to just keep in mind.
There is a moral panic on the right about this,
which doesn't mean that there's not something real,
there really is a huge problem,
but it's not as pervasive as it sometimes made out to be.
So is it a kin to looking at violence in the news media like you,
your,
when you read about violence in terms of robberies and murders in general,
you're not gonna encounter much in your life.
The world is a large place,
but we concentrate on these really bad moments.
Yeah,
it's a little bit like that except that,
um,
you know,
one of the reasons that we took child,
we took free play away from kids is that we were afraid that they'd be abducted
and that almost never,
and that was so rare.
Uh,
and,
but we got a lot of coverage of that in the eighties and nineties and we changed
our behavior because of that.
And that was a gross overreaction.
The situation on campus is,
is not like that.
It's,
it's your odds of being nailed are much higher than that.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I hear every day,
or at least every week I get an email from a professor who says,
you know,
I,
I used a metaphor in class and somebody reported me.
And like,
you know,
and so once this happens to you,
you,
you pull back,
you change your teaching style.
What we're seeing on campus is a spectacular collapse of trust between students
and professors.
And when we don't trust each other,
we can't do,
we can't do our job.
We can't,
we can't risk provoking being provocative,
raising new ideas,
raising uncomfortable ideas.
We have to play it safe.
And then everybody suffers.
Is social media partially to blame because it's huge.
Social media's a huge part of this problem.
So,
um,
uh,
in a couple ways,
um,
so one is the generational thing that we have,
uh,
kids born after 1995 got this in middle school.
It had a variety of effects on them.
So kids coming in are more conversant with call out culture.
And so that's a big part of this.
Um,
the other thing though is that we used to have what you would call a reasonable
person standard.
So,
uh,
you know,
so,
um,
you know,
for professor,
uh,
what's one now?
So professor just wrote to me recently,
he said he,
you know,
he got frustrated while trying to explain something and he said,
oh,
shoot me now.
Um,
and a student was offended by this because are you making fun of people
committing suicide and okay,
you know,
add,
she come to him and said,
you know,
professor,
I know you didn't mean anything,
but that was kind of incentive.
That would have been great.
Like that's the way to handle it.
But for this generation raised with call out culture and social media,
you almost never hear of a student coming to someone else in private because you
don't get credit for that.
So you only get credit when you call them out publicly.
And so that's why we're all walking on egg shells because most of our students
are great.
Most of them are fine.
But if I have a class of 300 students,
a lecture class,
I know that some of them subscribe to this new call out culture safety as a
morality.
And so if I say one thing,
it's not a reasonable person standard.
It's a most sensitive person standard.
I have to teach to the most sensitive person in the class.
It's also that person has the opportunity to score right there.
Exactly.
Throw up that virtue flag.
Like I've got one on the board here.
Look what I did.
I nailed the professor on saying shoot me now and now I'm a hero and I made this
a safer space for everybody else.
That's right.
And so and so.
That's really what is messing us up at so many levels of society and the fact
that a lot of these problems,
the difficulties of democracy,
the rise of authoritarian populism,
that there,
there are a lot of weird trends that are happening in multiple countries and I
think it's the rise of devices and social media is the main way we can explain
why it's so similar across countries.
Do you think that this is us,
is this some sort of a trend that will eventually correct itself when these kids
get out into the real world and then go through a whole generation of that and
then people realize the error of their ways and the disastrous results of having
these unprepared or emotionally unprepared kids?
No,
I'm pretty confident that it will not correct itself.
I think that once we understand it,
I think there are a variety of things we can do to change it.
But I think here's the way to understand it and why it's not going to change
itself.
So,
so I'm a,
I'm a social psychologist is my main,
my main area.
Um,
but I,
I love all of the social sciences.
I love thinking about complex systems and systems composed of people are really
different from systems composed of stars or new neutrons or anything else.
And so,
um,
if you have a complex system composed of people,
these people are primarily working to increase their prestige.
So,
I mean,
once we have our needs for,
you know,
food and things like that are set,
we're,
we're always interacting in ways to make ourselves look good,
uh,
and to protect ourselves from being nailed or accused of something.
So we're always doing reputation management.
Now.
Um,
think about in any group,
what gives you prestige.
And so if you look in a group of teenagers,
you might have a group,
uh,
in which it's athletics.
And so if that's how you get prestige,
then all the kids are going to be working out and training and practicing.
And that doesn't hurt anybody.
That doesn't impose an external cost on anyone else.
But you can have some really sick prestige economies.
Uh,
and so there's,
um,
there's an ethnography about a fill a,
I'm an indigenous population in the Philippines,
uh,
by Shelly Resolve.
I was the anthropologist,
I think it's called knowledge and passion about the along good,
which is a name for a,
a tribe in the Philippines.
And in this tribe,
it's a headhunting tribe.
They find people and cut off their heads,
not just for fun,
for prestige.
So in a lot of societies,
you have a lot of male initiation.
Boys have to do something to become a man.
And if the thing you have to do to become a man is you have to cut off someone's
head.
Okay?
So that imposes rather a heavy cost on outsiders.
All right?
So this is a sick culture.
This is not one where we can say,
oh well that's just the way they do things.
Okay,
this has to stop.
Um,
and ideally they would cut off a stranger's head.
Like they find someone from another tribe or someone,
you know,
from a government agency,
they're just cut off his head.
Um,
uh,
but if necessary,
if there's a fight or if there's somebody within their larger community that can
also get you points.
So this is a really sick culture now head now,
um,
call it culture is not quite that bad,
but it's the same logic.
Okay?
So if you have a group of teenagers or college students who are all struggling
for prestige as we all are,
and if you get a subculture in which the way you get prestige is by calling
someone out,
showing that they're racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
transphobic,
Islamophobic,
whatever it is.
If you can catch them,
you get the points.
What you're doing here is your imposing external costs on others.
And that's what makes you so insufferable because you are playing your game.
But I'm paying the cost of your game.
And so that,
I think it's hard,
people aren't going to break out of that themselves.
But once we understand what's happening,
I think in a sense we can all come together and call out,
call out culture and say,
stop,
stop imposing these costs on us.
But how are we going to reach those kids if professors are so terrified to speak
out and to cause controversy in class and no one wants to criticize them?
Because if you do,
you risk your job,
you risk them organizing against you.
And how does this shift?
So the,
so I'm hopeful that we can shift it because most people hate it.
So even the people who do and recognize that they're always on eggshells,
they can be next.
Um,
there's the tendency of people in this culture to,
you know,
as we say,
they eat their own,
they eventually turn on each other.
Um,
and the mental health costs of it.
I mean,
there are a number of essays that have been written by people who sort of left
that and it sounds miserable to be inside it.
You're always,
you know,
there's no humor,
there's no fun.
It's always,
you know,
hyper serious,
angry.
Um,
and so,
um,
so I think that,
I think if we can,
uh,
if we can raise kids or encourage them to see the games that social media makes
them do and give them a vocabulary.
I don't know what we should come up with some catchy terms for it,
but give them a vocabulary so that they can,
they can be like,
oh,
you're,
you know,
you're a calling out or I don't know,
that's a clunky,
but you know,
we can help them label this behavior as it mocket.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's patterns that you see in,
in people that
from a distance like a,
if I look at it,
when I look at them objectively,
there's like these,
these patents,
I go,
oh,
that's one of those Mager guys.
He's one of those,
you know,
he's got an American flag with an eagle in his avatar on Twitter rant.
If you go through his page,
it's all like talking great about POTUS and criticizing anyone who talks about
about trumpets.
It's strange.
It's like these patterns of behavior,
these predetermined pattern.
It's like there are stereotypes,
not just stereotypes,
like they've fallen into a well oiled slick groove that's very easy to predict.
If you are one of those people,
it's,
it's super easy to predict that you're going to be pro second amendment.
It's super easy to predict that you're probably going to be skeptical about
climate change.
There's all these different things that go along with these patterns of behavior
and you see them on the right.
You see him on the left and the it's,
it's weird to watch.
It's weird to watch on the outside.
I was like,
well,
this is such an easy pattern to slip into.
Yeah,
well that's right.
Um,
so,
uh,
there's data from the Pew surveys.
They've been measuring attitudes of Americans since the eighties or nineties.
Uh,
but they've been publishing this series on polarization in which they show that
in the 90s if you knew somebody that attitude on say,
gun control,
that would only predict their attitude on abortion a certain percent.
And a lot of people on the left,
let's say would hold six of the 10 leftist attitudes and same on the right.
But gradually by the time you get to around 2010,
it's like if you know one attitude,
you know them all.
And that's in part just because of you turn up the volume.
So we evolve to do us versus them and the more we see,
you know,
if it's us,
America versus them communist Russia or Nazi Germany,
what then,
you know,
then we all come together.
And that's great for social cohesion and trust.
Um,
but as that fades away and as us versus them became increasingly left versus
right,
and as we lost the liberal Republicans and the conservative Democrats,
those used to exist until the eighties or nineties as we lost them.
Once it becomes us versus them is left versus right now,
if you only hold your team's position on six out of 10 items,
you're a trader.
And so you better get with the program.
And so the pressures for conformity,
the pressures to agree with your team on everything had been steadily rising.
And that means there's no nuance and we can't do higher education without
nuance.
We can't do college without free thinking.
And the ability to say,
well,
you know what,
wait a second.
Maybe they do have a point on this,
on this thing.
And that's one of the reasons why it looks so weird from the outside and why
it's getting so unpleasant from the inside.
When you're teaching classes and a subject comes up that may be controversial.
Do you,
do you have like this overwhelming feeling that you're treading on dangerous
ground?
Yes.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I taught psych one and one at the University of Virginia and I would do all,
I would take them into,
you know,
sex differences,
origin of sex,
sexual orientation.
I would even do race differences.
Um,
and Eh,
you know,
because there was a reasonable person standard and I trusted my students and
they trusted me and we had a great time and we covered a lot,
a lot of stuff.
Um,
but now and then I moved to New York University in 2011.
uh,
when my last previous book,
the righteous mind came out and it's not a,
it's not about Uva versus Nyu is just about the changing time.
Um,
now,
as I said,
I have to teach to the most sensitive students.
So I teach a course on business ethics,
on professional responsibility,
and we have a section on,
um,
uh,
on discrimination and employment law.
It's important to cover it.
We have to cover it,
you know,
Mba students have to know where the lines are,
what the law is.
Um,
and yeah,
I'm kind of scared when I teach that.
Uh,
because you know,
I'd like to get into all sorts of things.
Um,
I'd like to get into,
well,
you know,
what to numerical disparities mean if there's a gender difference in,
in the percentage of tech but not in the percentage of non tech employers in
Silicon Valley.
Well,
what does that mean?
I would like to talk about that.
But if a single student thinks that I am denying the existence of sexism,
they could be offended by that.
And in every bathroom at Nyu,
there's a sign telling them how to report me anonymously and they put these up
in 2016 in response to student requests.
Um,
and that means that all professors are on notice that they can be reported
anonymously at any moment.
But children,
well,
these are,
I'm not going to call them children.
I mean,
my students were Mba students,
but,
uh,
but the undergrads,
there are 17,
17 to 21 year olds for the undergrads.
Yes,
that's right.
Barely not children anymore.
That's right.
And there's an incentive to this,
this what we were talking about before.
There's this incentive that gives them attention.
They get prestige,
they get value from it.
And this,
that this culture encourages these things.
That's right.